- NIGHT, RICO.
SEE YOU TOMORROW, BUDDY.
- YOU'RE THE BEST.
BYE, STASI, BYE, CHESKA.
UGH. WHERE'S THE CAR?
JUST PRESS IT.
IT'LL BOOP-BOOP IT.
- I PARKED IT RIGHT HERE,
REMEMBER?
I WAS LIKE, "LOOK AT THAT
CASH MONEY SPOT WE GOT."
- I WANT TO BE HOME
IN BED GRINDING MY TEETH.
- OH. WENDELLS,
OUR CAR GOT TOWED.
WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO DO?
GO DOWNTOWN AND RETRIEVE IT?
- WOULDN'T IT BE EASIER
JUST TO BUY A NEW ONE?
- ♪ MONEY, BIG MONEY,
BIG DOUGH ♪
[tires squealing]
[crash, car horn blaring]
- [groans]
WHY DO YOU HAVE TO DRIVE
WITH YOUR KNEES?
- I WAS TAKING A BONG HIT,
YOU IDIOT.
- UGH. YOU'RE BUYING
THE NEXT CAR.
- DON'T BE SUCH A JEW,
ASPEN.
- I'M ONLY HALF-JEWISH,
WENDY!
- WHATEVER!
- OH, MY GOD, ARE YOU GUYS OKAY?
- WE'RE FINE.
THIS HAPPENS, LIKE...
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF YOU'RE GOING BACK INSIDE,
CAN YOU JUST GET ME SOME
FRESH, CLEAN BOXERS?
I THINK I MADE A BOOM-BOOM
IN MY PANTS.
- I AM CALLING
THE POLICE.
- NO, NO!
- NO, NO, NO, NO!
LET ME SEE THAT.
- NO POLICIA.
- NO, NO, NO, NO.
NO POLICE.
- NO POLICIA.
ALCOHOLICO, ALCOHOLICO!
- GIVE HER MONEY,
GIVE HER MONEY.
- 20, 40...
- THANK YOU.
- 60...[retches]
- AH!
- OH, NO, OLD FAITHFUL.
UGH! OH, MAN.
- OKAY.
- I ACTUALLY FEEL, LIKE,
A LOT BETTER.
- WELL, YOU GUYS
ARE DISGUSTING PEOPLE.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT EVERYONE
HAD A LITTLE BIT OF GOOD
IN THEM, BUT...
I DON'T SEE IT WITH YOU.
[touching music]
- OH, MY GOD.
UNDIGESTED VICODINS.
- OH!
- ARE YOU JOKING ME?
- I GUESS I DID HAVE, LIKE,
A LITTLE BIT OF GOOD IN ME.
- [laughing] ASPEN, MAN!
OKAY.
- WE'RE VERY SORRY.
- SERIOUSLY.
- WE WOULD LIKE YOU
TO HAVE OUR CAR.
IT'S, LIKE,
A 2000 WHATEVER YEAR WE'RE IN.
AND, LIKE, TOTALLY ENJOY IT.
YOU'RE AWESOME.
- IT'S GREAT.
YOU'RE THE BEST.
- I DIDN'T
LIKE THAT CAR ANYWAY.
IT HAD, LIKE,
TOO MANY BUTTONS ON IT.
- DEFINITELY.
[underwear snaps loudly]